but i spend most of my time on the west
side i get up and leave
oh okay yeah it's good to get away from
this hell yeah you go crazy
or kill somebody all right trayvon
yes trayvon where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh south central
l.a
and uh tell me about your family you had
both your parents growing up yes
i was actually born with albinism
my mother was 15 when she had me
and i was born in 69 so
i was officially raised by my father's
parents
they took me away to home out of the
hospital
because mom was too young right in 1969
they wouldn't give a 15 year old
educated
little girl a blind white child it just
wasn't going to happen
and so that's how
i was raised with my grandmother
i didn't know my mother was my real
mother for years
wow and but
her and my father had their own separate
housing
they were still having my brother and
sister ready but i was
stayed there you know legally i was
never
awarded to my mother
my father and his parents yeah but i
grew up in a full
tribal like what kind of childhood do
you have
it was arduous you know it was
lots of violence
but i had a huge family to protect me
but it was a lot of violence
a lot of fighting a lot of teasing and
my family were very protective of me
and you know it was just
a lot of violence any uh like to
towards you as well i mean no yeah i had
to do a lot of fighting myself
you know just to get to education abuse
is mostly physical it sounds like
it was physical right because
it's like having albinism
where people don't understand they'll
try to destroy
it's something that they don't
understand and it's a lot of old wives
tales associated with
it people that the grand mama told them
this and this about people
such as myself and
it's all
untrue you know what i mean but it's
deeply entrenched within the subculture
within the society even in
africa they're hunting down people like
me and selling our body parts
and you never seen that
you know it's i won't even date an
african
so i'm scared they're gonna try and take
me to the congo and sell me
so so growing up did you
i mean did you see your i mean how do
you relate to the african-american
community
do you see yourself as black of course
yeah i mean i'm very happy
you're just you just it wasn't a big
issue in my household nobody ever talked
about it i was just a family member
i was just a baby growing up it wasn't
an issue it wasn't an
did it ever become an issue in your life
not for me
and if not for me i've never had the
issue right but for other people i mean
for me
it it got me jobs you know
i mean it's like there's something wrong
with you it's just like you're just you
just look different than everybody
right and i don't have to dye my hair
green to be outstanding
i see people go to great extremes just
so people can look at them when you walk
down the street
and i tell people um you know people
especially people that i date
and and they have to be warned i'm like
you've never been to war in public with
me
he said and i have to when i'm like when
we go up people are going to
look at us everywhere we go and people
and if you're not
used to that it will make you
uncomfortable if you never experienced
that
if you live this world where you just
blindly go through society
and no one even turns an eye but if
you're not used to that and i've
given up relationships because of that
they couldn't handle it
it would make them they're not used to
it you know they're used to being
invisible
you're beautiful to look at and do you
see yourself that way
i'm smart good answer
i'm smart that's great i see myself
smart oh that's beautiful too
i think i'm more smart than bertie but i
am grace jones sexy
you know i think your personality makes
you even more beautiful
i'm a hoot that i was a barton during a
biker bar
in santa barbara county i lived there
for 10 years ghost riders
it's i can say that because it's been
sold and
you know the copyrights or but but so
you've had jobs you've had
i worked at cedars-sinai hospital for
seven years
and i worked at king hospital in the er
for two years and
from 1988 to 1990 when la was the
gunshot capital of the world
and in 19 from 1988 to 1990
the military there's a landing base on
top of the hospital
they used to bring their medics in to
train them for gunshots
because if you get shot you want to
either go to
county lsc or king
because they have more gunshots they
they're more likely to
save you better than cedar sinai when it
comes to
gun wounds you know because the where
where it is i mean when i was growing up
uh before i started working because i
started working very young
i was a go-getter i was highly motivated
and when i first got the job
at king in the er
it's just all every day gunshot wounds
young boys young boys and they generally
stabilize them and it
it's changed now because they all killed
each other and went to jail
that's how it ended they slaughtered
they're off the street i saw it
you know before i was 18 i went to over
30 funerals
over 30 funerals my brother i
experienced myself
was murdered at the age of 15. his name
was maurice deshawn 1984
october the 14th i'll never forget that
day
and uh it was game violence but up and
down crenshaw boulevard
every day someone was murdered
it was never talked about in paper you
know and that's when mary tom bradley
who's here you know my family is a
church family so
we're kind of about
about not kind of we are about the
community and so we do go to community
counseling
we have a couple of family members on
the council boards and
you know just being part of the
community
but what truly changed a way
everyone who's here now they're not from
here
they're not from here you know and i'm
and
if you don't know me you're not from
here because
i've been here like
yeah i remember there was no tense
i remember when i remember when there
was no crips
you know you know my mother and father
were black panthers
and i learned that as i got older
because my father used to take me to the
meeting i was a little girl i just
served cookies
i don't know what the hell's going on
there's just people talking i didn't
know
the black panther party
i did not know that until my father he's
like baby girl don't you remember i'm
like
daddy you took me to black parts of me
like it was family
so uh the the the recent black lives
matter
things that have been going on in our
country how do you
how do you see that is does your
albinism
affect your my perspective of it yeah of
course
you know i really feel that the no from
an albino perspective
and this is for society's sake people to
put too much emphasis on skin color
number one
especially black people especially my
people
i mean within the subculture and
i've been affected by
gang violence you know within myself
within my culture and black lives
does matter but black people have to
embody that themselves first if they
want
other subcultures to recognize that it
has to be grass
root it has to be grassroot
and it has to be practiced religiously
and it's not just about you know
wanting some attention and being
political because this has gone on
before we burned the whole
city down because of one black life
and the whole city burned because of one
black life
so we embody that here in la
we totally do but then after
we burn the city down everybody get
tired you know
and then they just go back to the same
behavior which
manifests this what's going on now
to begin with you know
what created it is the behavior within
the subculture
you know if you want black lives to
matter you have to convey that every day
as a black person and it's silent
you know it's silent you don't have to
bark it out
just walk it practice it
do it and you know
you could say a lot by just doing it
and not just screaming out and you know
it's so many my son went to conoco park
high and it was in 2000 there was a
private war between hispanics in the
black
they were gunning people down this right
outside of chatsworth
2000 2002. they never put it in
newspaper because it wasn't nothing but
mexicans killing black and they wanted
those houses to sell
you know ralph orozco parthenia where
all the apartments are
they were slaughtering each other
walking down the street
and that's and and it was a silent war
and it was in a valley but
and a lot of the black parents a lot of
the black people who lost their children
walking home
didn't say anything you know if black
lives matter
make them matter you know as a black
person
you know i moved out to protect to say i
have a 31 year old son
who happens to be black i left conoco
park and moved to santa barbara
to save his life because there was
carnage and all these you know black
people who are expressing this need to
be noticed and recognized and respected
have to start doing it within the
subculture they have to do
it and if they want other people to do
it
you know no one's gonna do it for you
you know and uh and and i and i truly
feel deeply about this because
i lost her i was 14 when my brother died
and when i went to his funeral
it was closed caps because they shot him
in the face with a
off shotgun a 15 year old little boy
they shot his leg off
and then they shot him in the face up
close
and and this when l.a
was a war zone it was like beirut
i have to run home every day getting
shot at
just to get an education just to
graduate and in order to go to the
valley i would bust to the valley
because i got good grades
but [ __ ] the same [ __ ] that's
in you growing up with they in the hood
you could be they riding the bus with
you right
for real so it's fighting on the [ __ ]
school bus before you
get to the valley for real
like that and uh
but la has cleaned up a lot you know me
seeing it
it's it's a lot it's becoming more
diverse again
because all the game bangers and they
all killed each other they in jail and
they did
pretty much and uh it's just
and crack okay is not the drug of choice
anymore it's math
and that's a whole different beast way
different
you know and and it changed the climate
it changed the plains of l.a it's way
different now it's way more quiet people
more
but having this condition out here
one thing this happened to me i left
because i moved i moved to santa barbara
i stayed there for 10 years but i will
come back and
visit the house i grew up and was born
in
and i'm walking down the street going to
see my father and the police
swooped up next to me and said where the
hell do you think you're going what do
you think what are you doing here
i'm like i live here
what are you doing here and how
you're not from here you thought you
were white right and suited for me
and what the hell do you think you do
i'm like
what the hell do you think you're doing
see that house right there with all them
black people crazy one that you always
running up with to
that's my house i was born there they're
like oh
proceed they were like
because they they were new they were
rookies you know what i mean
have you have you seen other racist and
like reactions people that thought you
were oh yeah especially
why agent the most people
except black people they know i'm black
but outside my subculture
they uh they think i'm norwegian
anything but black
anything but then when they find out
you're black
i had to demand it i'm like check this
out
then i showed them and they're like oh
okay i believe you
but you know it's it's um it's funny
it's entertaining it makes me laugh to
how people respond to me how they behave
how they stare
so rude
but you know i i managed to
have fun with it make money off of it
you know you know they hire me
just to be me i don't have to do nothing
but be myself
and if [ __ ] don't like what
they see they can turn their head and
look the other way
right yeah it's interesting how you you
you've turned something that could be
something that keeps you down into
something that oh it made me money
i got all the every job even getting
that job at cedars-side now hospital
i was a hospital i was a coordinator
there of the communication between the
doctors and the nurses
and all the girls they had they had an
exotic look
and i was 23 22 22 when i started
working there
and and we were all friends we were all
secretaries
but each one of us had an exotic
blood and that's what they it's
hollywood
and i know that's how i got that job i
know that's how that i know that's why
they hired me
not only could i i you know i was able
to type and
you know do the job but also
it's hollywood you're fun to look at
i'm like wow look at me
so what what what your interesting
perspective
on being african american
what insights can you share that we all
believe
from i mean race
of the way mankind uh said it's only one
race human race
the word race as a separate of the
ethnicity is a construct
we all of us bleed from it into the same
cup
and i'm living proof of that and and
that's the only thing that i've learned
and no one told me this this is
something that i came to
understand just being this way dealing
with society
you know and i've traveled i've been in
london i've been doing makeup in canada
you know and stepping outside
and it's in people like me even outside
the united the state boundary there's
very superstitious about people like me
jamaica forget it you know they're like
i'm a witchy woman you know and
i am no i am
but but the society and the
superstitions and what people believe
you know and if
and it's it's called a construct if a
lot of people say it enough
it becomes true
what i see after talking with so many
people
is if you believe you're a victim you
are you're a victim
right and it would be very easy for
somebody who is
willing to victimize well i mean if you
think generationally
if somebody's you know living in poverty
and they're african-american and
they're you know they're a victim right
but if they chose to not be a victim
and do kind acts for other people in the
dimensions of
all wealth backgrounds and everything
right and just be a kind of person that
everyone goes
wow i met that dude yesterday i can't
stop thinking about them
right and if that kept happening
generation after generation
then there would be no victimization of
anyone
correct it would just be like oh my god
these people are great right
i met three of them last week and they
one was nicer than the next
but that that doesn't seem to be
happening right now well
and see that's my point people i mean
there's lots of demands to treat me
better great i understand that but
you have to manifest it you have to
practice it you
you have to do it you know and then
it and if you and if you convey it in it
into as convenience as a practice
you know you're doing it you don't have
to say nothing it's you convey it
and you just don't walk in a room and
demand respect
you can't do that especially not down
here
not down here and then and you know
believe it or not on scare roar
it's a huge melting pot here for the
silent
especially with the asians but we've
been like this for years
you know i mean asians in the black down
here the
the hispanic the mexicans and the el
salvador they run
macarthur part that has always been
black territory
always and a lot of in
what keeps me alive down here half of
these [ __ ] are related to me
they got babies by people in my family
and marrying my family you know what i
mean they know me
and that's why i didn't [ __ ] with me
because they know me and the people who
don't know me
don't know who watching them
and you know because being albino down
here that's the only thing keeps me safe
have these muscle related to me because
trust me if i came down here by myself
and didn't know nobody
it would have been a slaughter you know
look
they're all predators
they live in intense because they off
the radar
they're running from the feds whoever
right
pharrell they're running from everybody
and themselves
and themselves what's the most important
lesson you've learned toronto
no one's above it no one's greater
or lesser we're all the same and truly
and it's not
the color of a person's skin
dr king says the creed you know it's
their character
and their practice and their behavior
and as a black
person and a white person you know
because black people and white people
stay separated so they don't really know
each other we're just getting
in la is different we bend together out
here but people from other places bring
in that separatism here we never had
that here
when i grew up in south central my
family were home owners
it was asian people on the house next
door we used to play together
you know it was white people it wasn't
in the 80s and 70s in la
it was a melting pot and even watts to
her car sent
white people still live there own the
houses they probably rent them out now
but they're still original owners and we
all grew up together which just
you know i mean even the jungle now
white people are starting to come back
the jews they wasn't giving up their
property they still own it they were
just leasing it
and now i knew that i grew up out there
right over there midtown
uh pico redondo houser cop
yo hancock park i
tore that place up no i thought
and that's all i gotta say about that
what's your favorite personality trait
that you have
hmm you have a lot of them
when i'm nervous i like to tell jokes i
like to tell joe
it breaks your eyes it makes people
laugh and it gives you time to think of
something
else that's when you're trying to escape
you crack a joke one day laughing you
creep into the door to get out
what do you think would help our society
most this is a rough time for a lot of
people
what do you think what do you think we
should pay more attention to
people should pay more attention to
themselves
and make themselves a better person if
you're working on yourself you wouldn't
have time to look and criticize someone
else
you wouldn't be paying attention to them
because you would be too busy doing what
you're supposed to be doing
and if each individual did
their job we would run like [ __ ]
canada
and and it would be a well functioning
society
generation after generation after
generation at the g it'll manifest but
you could be a better role model for
your kids and your kids
yeah and but it has to did that's the
type of family i came from
i mean we had killer scholars healers
and killers
you know i had school teachers
doctors not in my family but you know i
got to do both sides of the spectrum and
it was because of my albinism
that i was accepted i've been places
that my sisters and brothers can't
come in because of color their skin they
won't invite
you in you have to be able to blend in
with the family photos
especially when you outside your outside
your soap culture when you're in a white
society
it's easier again if you look like them
it's no question
they don't question it but um
but if most people as individuals pay
more attention to themselves
and and contribute
you know and be self-motivated get off
your ass and do something right
quit barking and complaining about what
you're not getting if you're not
getting up and trying to get it yourself
it's not going to be handed to you
and that's all i gotta say about that
excellent trayvon thank you so much for
talking with me
you're fabulous oh you're just saying
that because it's true
you